[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben wir machen heute ein
total praktisches dessert nämlich
pudding röllchen wie pudding röhrchen
sind so schnell und einfach zubereitet
wenn ihr die wartezeit außer acht lässt
dann seid ihr innerhalb von 30 minuten
schon fertig im türkischen sind sie auch
bekannt unter den namen sunrise masse
oder aber sultan zahl müsse jetzt zeige
ich euch aber zuallererst die zutaten
für den schokoladenpudding wir benötigen
milch egal ob fettarme oder vollmilch
außerdem mail bei kakao zucker und
butter in einen ausreichend großen topf
geben wir jetzt die komplette milch das
mehl den zucker und dem ba cacau
[Musik]
jetzt wird das ganze gut miteinander
verrührt der herd ist an der stelle auch
noch nicht eingeschaltet die hitze
benötigen wir erst nachdem alles gut
verrührt wurde
[Musik]
sobald das ganze unter ständigem rühren
einmal aufgekocht ist dick dass auch
schon ein und ich schalte den herd auf
mittlere stufe
anschließend geben wir die butter mit
hinzu und lassen das in den
schokoladenpudding schmelzen
das ganze muss jetzt noch zwei minuten
lang weiter köcheln wird dann ist der
schokoladenpudding fertig nun arbeiten
wir mit unserem backblech weiter und das
streue ich mit reichlich kokosraspeln
aus
wir sind schritt erledigt ihr am besten
bevor ihr den pudding zubereitet denn im
pudding geben wir jetzt noch heiß direkt
vom herd auf die cocos schicht den
heißen putting verteilen wir so
gleichmäßig wie möglich auf dem
backblech und nehmen uns dann eine
winkel palette zur handlung das ganze
noch mal glatt zu streichen
es ist wichtig dass ihr diesen schritt
erledigt sobald der pudding fertig ist
ansonsten zieht er eine unschöne haut
und dann habt ihr nur unnötige stückchen
mit drin
falls ihr keine kokos fans seid dann
gehen natürlich auch gemeinde nüsse oder
streusel oder was sie sonst noch da habt
[Musik]
jetzt muss das ganze vollständig
auskühlen es muss komplett kalt gestellt
werden damit wir mit der sahne
weitermachen können
für diesen schritt benötigen wir sahen
die muss ganz kalt sein und seine stand
mittel
[Musik]
sobald die sahne dann komplett steif
geschlagen ist geben wir sie auf unseren
ausgekühlten pudding
[Musik]
die sahne wird jetzt nur noch als ganz
dünne schicht auf dem pudding verteilt
und dann geht es auch schon weiter
[Musik]
um die stückchen einzuteilen nehmt ihr
euch am besten irgendein stumpfen
gegenstand damit das backblech auch
nicht ruiniert ist umfang an das ganze
aufzuteilen
hierfür schneiden wir den pudding in der
mitte einmal waagerecht komplett durch
[Musik]
anschließend schneiden wir von oben nach
unten in der mitte einmal durch und
schneiden das dann noch mal jeweils in
der mitte so dass wir acht gleichmäßig
große stücke erhalten
[Musik]
nun werden die stücke vorsichtig von der
einen seite bis zur anderen aufgerollt
[Musik]
die pudding röllchen halten übrigens
drei tage falls ihr keine frische sahne
verwendet halten sie sogar noch länger
[Musik]
die pudding brötchen sind übrigens
relativ stabil
also auch wenn du so ein stückchen noch
herunterhängen das könnt ihr alles auf
dem teller noch begradigen
[Musik]
ich hoffe natürlich sehr dass euch
dieses dessert genauso überzeugt hat wie
mich wollt ihr das jetzt ganz fleißig
nach macht die genauen mengenangaben
stehen wie immer unten in der infobox
und dann freue ich mich über fotos mit
dem hashtag ig sketchen auf instagram
[Musik]
falls ihr gerne noch mehr varianten
dieser leckeren pudding röhrchen von mir
sehen möchtet dann schreibt sie mir
gerne in die kommentare denn ich habe
noch so einige ideen und abwandlungen
die ich euch gerne zeigen würde
[Musik]
ansonsten freue ich mich sehr wenn ihr
mich abonniert damit ihr auch keines
männer videos mehr verpasst und dann
sage ich bis zum nächsten mal auf die
dies kitchen
[Musik]